[Music]
hey you guys
happy sunday yeah
it's sunday we're kind of sleepy
although
we didn't go out late last night i
didn't even think i drank last night you
did yeah you had some left over from
from the other day from the other day it
was still sitting there you're like hey
what's still good we'll put it here just
put ice in instead of
just perfectly preserved
so we saw that uh we saw this new movie
what's called midnight nightmare
nightmare alley nightmare alley that's
what it is
and it's a movie i it looked like it was
going to be some kind of supernatural
horror movie or or something it's
neither it but it's good it's really
good
uh it's got um it's about carnies
and the weird [ __ ] the weird grips and
[ __ ] that they were doing
and it [ __ ] turned into some [ __ ]
pretty dark
pretty dark stuff and it's from a book
and there's an older movies
that this comes from but guillermo de
toro he this is his interpretation of it
that's [ __ ] good it's real good
even the the sets it's happening back in
the 40s the 30s and the 40s
and it trans transports you back there
it looks it looks authentic
some of these old [ __ ] buildings i
don't know where was that chicago
uh buffalo new york buffalo new york
the yeah some of it was filmed above
some of it was filmed in uh canada but a
lot of it was filmed in buffalo real
high-end art deco [ __ ] buildings and
offices and
good
sets and stuff taking place in [ __ ]
carnivals with
weird acts going on and
a bunch of grifters grifters and
criminals and hobos and
you expect [ __ ] panzram to show up
start raping me
that's all kind of stuff happens yeah
it's good i enjoyed it i mean i yeah i
did too i have to say um it's not gonna
be for everybody but
i legit loved this movie i mean
i think really i've seen like a lot of
critics really seem to be digging it and
some were like well it's a little bit
too long it's long it's two and a half
hours
but
it didn't really i mean
honestly i was just like captivated the
whole time it was such an interesting
story
told this dude's um story about why he
joined the carnival
he killed somebody they don't really get
into it but you know that he did
or you see him hiding the body and then
he joins the carnival and then once he's
in the carnival starts a new life and
learns all these skills and becomes a
mentalist
but he steals those skills from another
dude
and it's like he's like a sith lord and
all of a sudden he's kind of believing
his [ __ ] he they were warned about you
know they warned him about it says you
know the old mentalist was like you
might start believing your own [ __ ] and
get you and get yourself into big
trouble and it happens
he's getting to where he could just
almost like read people's minds and you
start buying into it then maybe this is
some kind of psychic ability but then he
comes back no no no and he explains how
he did it
but he was so good at it
you go well it may as well be
supernatural so it kind of fueled his
[ __ ] head and his ego getting bigger
and bigger and
he started getting greedy he started
getting greedy he gets in with [ __ ]
rich dudes goes up through lawyers and
the next thing you know these [ __ ]
billionaire
[ __ ] rockefeller type dudes who
[ __ ] need him to contact the dead and
[ __ ]
and it turns out that these dudes are no
good man they got their own [ __ ]
private security yeah pretty much every
character yes it's terrible
[ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] goes back to
what i've been telling you people over
the [ __ ] years the more power and
[ __ ] wealth to do to cruz the more
suspect he is there's a reason why he
got that way and it gets into that even
though it's kind of a side they're just
he had a problem he's basically almost
like a serial killer in a way or it
infers that maybe he is one it's
difficult to say
oh you just have to see the movie
but he's threatening him you know
[ __ ] you do this in that [ __ ]
you're going to see what i do to you you
know this is just a [ __ ] rich dude
with
he's got a bodyguard he yeah yes i
recognize him from another movie he's
just he was on mind hunter mine hunter
yeah i mean he's been in autonomy he's
been in a ton of [ __ ] but he was in a
mine he was yeah he's kind of like a
private detective but he's [ __ ] looks
like something from the mafia kind of
like a mixture of the both and he'll
kill you with a [ __ ] heartbeat his
loyalties are he he loves that old dude
because it was what he did for him so
he'll do anything for him
including [ __ ] commit murder
and this guy's [ __ ] just bloated
and um
this medalist just gets himself deeper
and deeper falls in with this
uh psychologist and turns out she's as
bad as he is she she's or maybe worse or
she's worse predator too she's doing the
same thing he's doing it's just he's
she's using the um
psychotherapy to do it but it's the same
thing building these [ __ ] out
of money
it's a good flick real good real good
yeah i mean she's like mind powers on a
[ __ ] like she's a damn jedi
they're like she's this [ __ ] sith
lord and crap
but she's just doing it and using a
different style and it's all grounded in
reality it's not
yeah because i kind of feel like i think
maybe i i kind of feel like maybe people
would be surprised that guillermo del
toro would make a movie like this
because his whole thing he likes to do
like supernatural or more like fantasy
type stuff um i think this is the first
movie that he's done that has no
supernatural elements whatsoever
um but you can actually see
why he would want to do a movie like
this it's not what he would usually do
but i really think he brings something
to this now yeah so there was this was
actually based on a novel which came out
in 1946
by william lindsey gresham and then they
made um a version of it in 1947 with um
tyron power
now interestingly i'm not going to spoil
the android because this movie is like
super new so i don't really want to like
spoil the end and i really do i mean as
i said it's not going to be for
everybody but i loved it i thought it
was like so so good
um
but interestingly the 1947 version
has a little bit of a more hopeful
ending
this one uh has the same ending as the
book which is uh pretty [ __ ] bleak
gotta say
uh this is essentially
what it is it's like a road to ruin type
story
um you know there's a lot of stuff going
on but you're basically following stan
who's like the main character stan
carlisle i think his name is
um
and
how he
you're following him throughout like
several years of his life
how he gets into these situations how he
gets in with the carnival and then he
gets all these powers and then like he's
this big success but the thing it's
almost kind of like a tragic downfall
type story because you know
as you're watching him he's not a good
person and i mean as the movie goes on
you kind of like him but you kind of
like him but he's almost like an
anti-hero but then as the movie goes on
you're like oh wow he's like he reveals
himself to be like a shittier and
shittier person like the whole time it's
it's like pop
the story is about power and karma you
can have power but in a way you kind of
have to pay for it and everything kind
of comes back when it which which is
and it's it's basically the same kind of
laws about witchcraft
you can cast a spell but it costs you
like what happened oh ed harley
using these mentalists to build the
mentalist powers and griffs on people it
comes back if you do it if you start
abusing it too hard and it kind of
and it kind of drawn parallels between
grifton
using
carney griffs and use it and the kind of
grips that a psychotherapist or
scientist or a doctor or any kind of
professional you can scamify or griftify
anything and that's really what the
carney lifestyle is about and they're
just showing it that it extends outside
of carnivals into the [ __ ] wider
world it's showing a world of corruption
how anything can be used as a weapon
but there's karma you you you pay for it
eventually especially if you use it too
much
that's what i picked up from it well and
as i said too it's kind of
based around your main character who i
think like bradley cooper was a good
choice for this because you know he's a
good-looking dude and he's kind of a
charming dude and you don't want to
believe that he's as terrible a person
as he is because of how he looks in the
st setting and his costumes you kind of
see him as indiana jones but he's not
but he reminds you a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] of indiana jones to me
yeah he does have that kind of vibe to
him yes it's kind of like i was looking
at
looking at uh [ __ ] oh what's his name
harrison harrison ford harrison ford
i've never really seen him play a bad
guy
but as it starts to unfold you see they
give him these abilities they tell him
but this is
the dude warns him says that you know
there's limits to this
eventually you'll start
if you start believing your own [ __ ]
it's going to lead you down a bad path
and that's that's really what the story
is about yeah i mean everybody like tri
was warning him or warn him about what
he's doing but as i said his you know
his fatal flaws were one greed yeah
because he got in like and he was making
more and more money because of this scam
that he was running with the
psychoanalyst yeah and also his
overconfidence in his own abilities he
thought that he could just do anything
he was good at it he started to believe
it in a certain sense but he really yeah
he really did kind of start to start to
believe in his own invulnerability his
own infallibility and he was right about
a lot of [ __ ] but
but then he come it seems supernatural
but then he'd come back and he'd explain
how he thought that
but he was pretty accurate yeah
it makes you wonder like when so you
start to it kind of blurred the lines
well it may as well be supernatural so
next you know he's believing his own
[ __ ] he's believing in his own magic
very much like [ __ ] um
l ron hubbard
and those cult leaders start doing they
just start believing their own [ __ ]
they start to think they're infallible
that they're supernatural in some weird
way or that it may as well be
supernatural it's not
but it comes back on them kind of like
something supernatural eventually anyway
has to do with geeking and i don't want
to spoil it but they they yeah it's like
a geek
and that scene between him and willem
dafoe is so good i mean willem dafoe is
great in this he's not in it a lot he's
kind of like the guy that runs the tenon
one that he first goes to the carnival
and um he's such a sleaze yeah he's just
like he's so [ __ ] good at this and
that conversation where he tells them
about like how they how they get geeks
from yeah for the old-time carnies yeah
making a geek is about exploiting the
weakness of [ __ ] a person who's
already got kind of like a drug and
alcohol pro problem
how you can take a person like that
and [ __ ] magnify it and make money
off of it
and
which is [ __ ] highly highly [ __ ]
immoral but these dudes are [ __ ] bad
they're like [ __ ] sorcerers that's
what i mean pretty much everybody no i'm
not going to say everybody like because
um not all of them are bad bernie mara's
character molly yeah um she's a good
person and you know some of the other
carnies uh you know we're good people
but the dude running the carnival um you
know bradley cooper's character cate
blanchett's character the femme fatale
these were all terrible terrible people
yeah um you know what i mean but very
very entertaining to watch them it's a
very seedy yeah but i liked that about
it so it's like the first half of it
like i said it's a lot it's long it's
like two and a half hours like the first
half of it or the first third of it
takes place at the carnival in 1939
um and i really dug that because i mean
we've done a show about like old side
shows and stuff like that i love that
kind of stuff i love the aesthetic of it
i just love all those old carnivals like
those like [ __ ] freak shows and
pickled punks in the jars and [ __ ] like
that so that's like the first third and
then it goes to like it jumps ahead two
years to
where um you know bradley cooper's
character stan and molly have kind of
like
they've kind of gone up in the world
they have this really good mentalist act
and you know everybody comes to see so
they have like a lot of rich people
coming to see them so they're making
money and then it's kind of like goes
into
as i said his his overweening ambition
uh and he gets in with
cate blanchett's character whose name is
lilith by the way they didn't really say
like i think i don't even think they
call her by because she's a she was a
psychoanalyst but it said on the door
okay yeah i don't think he ever
mentioned her name yeah
i mean she had the you know they her
name was doctor whatever her last name
was but her first name was
the [ __ ] perfect 40s dame [ __ ]
show yeah she was [ __ ] with her legs
and her [ __ ] mannerisms and her
outfits just like a she looked like a
40s supermodel she just [ __ ] look she
but it's all just part of her
special secret abilities i mean they're
like [ __ ] jedi and sith there's like
light side
there's light side [ __ ] carny
abilities or light side scams and dark
side scams that's and it's
it's that kind of [ __ ] it's like bad
it's like
white witches and [ __ ] sorcery that's
exactly what kana what what it's talking
about i believe um
there was
there's a there's a [ __ ] not a what
do you call it
there's some parallels there between
what they're doing and magic
or sorcery
yeah
you picked that you picked that yeah
yeah okay
that wasn't my imagination i don't
believe
yeah sheila ann says uh houdini used to
do a mentalist act with bess early in
his career yeah that's right yeah um i
think we did a show about houdini a long
time ago now that i'm thinking about it
we should maybe revisit that because i
love all that kind of stuff and all that
spiritual this kind of stuff um
yeah
some people are pointing out because you
said harrison ford had never played a
bad guy i was like yeah i'm pretty sure
he did yeah some people oscar perez says
what lies beneath yeah he's a bad guy
that's actually pretty good is it good
um
in the conversation he was a bad guy in
that mango yeah so he so he has been a
bad guy
um yeah so it's kind of like watching
harrison ford
if i felt like i was watching harrison
ford
yeah you know it's just just you know
sorry
you don't seem to agree with me but no i
mean no i know what you're saying it's
like he didn't really give me that vibe
but i see what you're talking about gave
me very much like a harrison ford doing
indiana jones as a mentalist it just it
just felt like that to me but like i
said i think that that's why he was a
good choice for this because
you don't see him as a threat you know
well you don't see him you don't want
him to be a bad guy because he seems you
know he's a good-looking dude and he's
like charming yeah and
at first like when he goes to the
carnival like he's doing helpful [ __ ]
you know what i mean like he's helping
them out and he you know when he first
meets molly
you know he he like uh makes her act
better you know because she's like an
electric girl yeah like they used to
have the old carnival side shows and uh
you know he builds her an electric chair
and like he does like ups her game you
know what i mean and so he seems like
a good like you know he's not a good
dude because the very first scene of the
movie he's buried so is him like putting
a dead body in the floor and like
burning a house down so but you don't
know what the context of that is you're
like well it's probably not good like
for sure he killed somebody it looks
like it's deniable though but you don't
know i don't know what the deal was
right you don't know what the deal was
with that um you find out later on so
you don't want to see him as a bad guy
yeah but as things go on [ __ ]
he's good and but some bad things happen
around him and you're like wait a minute
hold on
did he do that you don't know
but then as it kind of
unfolds you're like oh no yeah he did
like i said that's kind of like the more
the movie goes on i'm like oh my god
he's just like
he just gets shittier and shittier
he's grifting you
he's scamming you that's what i mean
that's why he was like a good and
honestly when they made the 1947 version
they did a similar kind of mind game
because they had tyron power who was
this very very handsome charming actor
so they want i mean yeah you're kind of
like running the same grift on the
audience because it's like you don't
want to believe this good looking
charming dude is
a sociopath yeah essentially for himself
right yeah and but you know and then as
it goes on you're just kind of like oh
man this dude sucks like oh my god he's
terrible but um yeah well like i said a
lot of people in this are terrible uh
you know willem dafoe's character he's
he's a terrible person like i said most
of the carnies are are not seem nice
enough well you don't know a lot about
you don't know a lot about them because
they're mostly like but i mean well i
assume that a lot of them are bad except
the electric girl well the yeah she
seemed like kind of an innocent i mean
she wasn't that a strong man and the
strong man yeah ron perlman yeah um you
know he was very protective of her yeah
and well
yeah with him he seemed easy and well
and it seemed to me too that um madame
zena you know tony collette's character
and her husband who were the ones where
who bradley cooper like learned all the
mentalist stuff from they seemed like
pretty nice people
like his cardis go she was using him to
get ahead when he was getting too old he
was getting she was getting ready to
discard him for the younger one
she was a predator too
although it was sexy well it was but i
don't know i'm kind of going back too
it's an open relationship though with
that well that's what i'm saying because
i think in the book
um there wasn't any whiff of that like
she wasn't like a bad person necessarily
i don't think like at least from what i
could determine from the
from the plot synopsis because i haven't
read the book
but
yeah she didn't seem like a bad person
necessarily the way i interpreted it is
that she was going to replace the old
the old guy with him that's how i yeah
and
which
well she he was used up anyway well he
couldn't help her anymore because he was
a drunk he was a drunk and he was she
still loved him though yeah he was on
his way out so she had to make a living
yeah but yeah so yeah he was like
supposed to help her out with her with
her mental acting he couldn't do any
more because he kept like falling asleep
on a job going to sleep on the job and
stuff because he was just like drinking
all the time but they showed they showed
him as a sympathetic character though
like he wasn't a bad person and she
wasn't
well no we don't know that either i'm
just saying he warned him about the
power of that magic so he did something
bad
it's just you don't know about remember
yeah well he just said just don't start
believing your own [ __ ] yeah which
might have implied that maybe he started
he did that at some point in the past
and it didn't go well it didn't go well
right um because why was he a drunk yeah
it might have been some kind of regret
of something that he had done
because of that mentalist grift
the power that mentalism could get you
so that's how i interpreted that is that
he had a downfall
because yeah he believed his own [ __ ]
but he but he learned that he was trying
to do a good thing by warning yeah stan
and stan didn't listen yeah because stan
thought he knew better [ __ ] stan but
uh yeah so so like i said that's kind of
like the whole thing it's this cyclical
um
tragic story like a tragic downfall type
of story and it is very bleak and it's
very seedy
um but i kind of love that and honestly
you know how people like sometimes they
say oh that you know why don't they make
movies like like that anymore um this is
a movie that's the kind of movie that
they don't really make much anymore
because this movie
i don't know how much it costs to make
but it was i'm sure it was a lot because
it's [ __ ] gorgeous
same cinematographer as shape of water
so you know he's it's his same
cinematographer that he's worked with
before uh who's dutch i think but um
but it looks gorgeous
it's you know uh an actor's ensemble
it's just like talent out the wazoo and
this is an r-rated
adult
you know not adult film like a porno
film but an adult it's geared toward an
older audience it's not superheroes it's
not an action movie it's a drama and
it's like a slow burn
type they and it's real bleak and
depressing and [ __ ] like that but it's
like
and i kind of feel like they released it
the same [ __ ] weekend as the new
spider-man movie so you know it was
going to get its ass kicked i wouldn't
call it bleak and depressing the end is
kind of like whoa
yeah but it's the movie yeah because
that last scene i think we both were
just like oh no
oh no because we saw where it was going
i was i was going along with it the
whole time you know i was kind of
riveted i was like okay what's gonna
happen next because it was interesting
so yeah it really i i did not find it it
never bored me it never it's long but it
didn't really i was just like enthralled
like the whole time i thought it was
fascinating it's real good um and it's
kind of like a kind of like a noir kind
of like a detective movie
and an old gangster movie
and almost like a
movie about witches and supernatural and
carnies and mentalist powers like i said
i love [ __ ] about it's all kind of
coming in together
in one thing and basically
most of the main characters are either
some kind of [ __ ] psychopath or a
sociopath and they range from being
[ __ ] dirt poor like bums
up to billionaires and they're all about
the same
yeah in terms of being i will say too
that one thing that kind of
didn't shock me but i wasn't expecting
it is that
in kind of the third act when [ __ ]
starts going sideways like with his
grifts and everything um there's some
pretty intense
violence yeah that i wasn't really
expecting i was like oh there's the
guillermo del toro i know i'm in love
you know what i mean where yeah some of
the violence in it is like pretty pretty
gross and but that's you know
so i guess that just kind of surprised
me because up until then yeah it hadn't
really you hadn't really seen much of
that but
i mean i don't know i just i really
really liked this a lot and i'd be
shocked if uh if i saw
this this might be this might be my
favorite movie i've seen this year it's
yeah it's i don't know i think i like
bond a little bit better but
it's it's it's up there this is a
serious movie real good real fun i
recommend it i will almost say it's a
masterpiece it's a masterpiece of what
it is
um of this type of movie and i've never
really seen one like this yeah i mean
it's a neo-noir yeah um
but
i don't know it's just it has i guess
like the original one was a lot more
gritty or whatever this one is very lush
but it's also i mean just the look of it
because it's you know guillermo del toro
and that's kind of his thing but
it's also like like i said it's really
seedy and it has like a really seedy
kind of vibe to it yeah well it's kind
of rooted in reality yeah nothing
happens out of character
like the violence isn't just out of
nowhere there's reasons for it yeah and
it's all like like stuff that would
likely happen
some of the stuff i knew i was like oh
this is good i know how this is gonna go
yeah this can only go one way and that's
how it goes
the nation has seen that [ __ ] common
well like i said that's that's the
tragedy of the film is that
because of his
because he thinks he's like too much of
himself
you can see how he's going to downfall
and he before he sees it yeah and so it
almost like surprises him he's like oh
[ __ ] right [ __ ] went bad even though
everybody tried to warn him everybody
but like i said that was his tragic claw
that's kind of like and like every time
somebody does something that's [ __ ] up
it makes sense that they did it that way
yeah the characters in this are awesome
make sense are very well drawn i thought
nobody does anything out of character
you would go yeah well if i was in that
position that's that's i would probably
have done that you know because so there
isn't any
characters that act stupidly or
characters that [ __ ] well yeah let's
put this away there aren't any
characters that act
in ways contrary to what seems to be the
right thing to do at the time
aside from dudes getting greedy or what
their character did right yeah dude just
keeps getting greedy just because he
fooled a judge now he's gonna fool
he keeps going up the goddamn ranks the
next thing you know he's basically
dealing with william randolph hearst or
a [ __ ]
rockefeller yeah i'm gonna bring back
the dead for you you know and i'm like
dude come on
well everybody was telling him that like
let's you're gonna can't wait not yeah
that's not gonna work out the way that
he's gonna work out he's gonna make this
illusion of bringing him back to dead
so he can get a couple more hundred
thousand dollars when he's already
gotten a fortune out of the dude all you
gotta do is just say i can't do it it's
not within my abilities but see he can't
do that
because his character that's not what
his character is yeah his character is
he thinks he can i would have told him
okay man that's it that's all i can do
and i'm like you've already got about a
million and a half dollars out of you
yeah but i can't you know that's good in
1941 yeah i gotta go you know
but oh you know what for an extra 200
000. yeah i can bring her back yeah
totally i'm gonna bring i'm gonna bring
her back and i'd be like oh this is
gonna go so badly
that's gonna go so fast yeah yeah and it
does
yeah well like i said
that's his whole character like he just
couldn't
uh thank you no need for me too
saw the new spidey so good i said that's
everybody says it's good yeah i'll
probably we'll probably go see it i mean
i don't really care about seeing it one
way or the other um you know like i said
i'm not there a lot of them are good but
i'm not really into the superhero movies
so the trailer for morpheus just looks
good morbius morbius yeah that actually
does look good
yeah i like the ones about the villains
like the or he's not really i don't
think he's really he's kind of like kind
of like the punisher where he's i think
he's kind of like both maybe yeah yeah
so he's not he's not really like yeah i
think it was more like a venom type of
thing where he's kind of like
conflicted
good and bad at the same time he's a
vampire i don't know yeah he's kind of
like a vampire that does look good and
actually the new matrix looks pretty
good
um but yeah it's it kind of like like i
said it kind of bums me out i'm not
really sure what they were aiming for
releasing nightmare alley the same week
as spider-man because like i said you
know it was gonna get crushed but
i don't know i was reading something
else too that said oh well sometimes
studios will do that because you know
you're going to get the younger
demographic [ __ ] like that going to see
spider-man whereas nightmare alley is
geared more toward an older audience so
they're trying to you know diversify uh
the audiences that are going to come out
that week or you know maybe your kids
want to go see spider-man and you don't
want to see it and you know what
whatever but
i mean i you know what i'd actually be
shocked if this didn't get nominated for
some oscars because it's already been
nominated for a bunch of like critics
choice awards and stuff like that
i liked about it is that it's kind of
like a period piece it is like a movie
from an earlier age but it [ __ ] just
looks great there's no nothing modern in
it at all
nothing yeah i mean it's really well all
the production design in this is [ __ ]
gorgeous right there's no modern
messaging there's no product placement
they're just
it is like they're telling a classic
tale
yeah now i'm actually now i want to read
the book
to be honest with you i'll read the book
and i want to see the because i was
going to actually watch the original too
but i didn't have time like before we
did this today because
you know we went yesterday
we went to the 3 45 show so it let out
at probably like seven o'clock and we
went to see it at the altamonte mall
and it's the weekend before christmas
right uh so we couldn't find a place to
park we couldn't even get in the food
court in the mall it was [ __ ]
packed the mall was [ __ ] packed the
entire parking lot was full
every parking lot was full yeah you were
like driving around like looking for a
space like by the [ __ ] yeah and then
we're like [ __ ] it we're just gonna go
so we went we had to drive like a couple
miles away and went to koi won like the
buffet and then drove all the way back
to see the movie there weren't that many
people in the theater
but when we came out there was like a
[ __ ] ton of people so i guess like there
was all these people were seeing
spider-man probably i want to see you i
think it's black adder that's must be
coming out black adam black adam that's
this black out
black outer what's that british yeah
that's that british comedy tv show
rowan atkinson i think that might have
something to do with shazam i don't know
if that's part of the show it is reverse
it is yeah um is that shazam 2 or is it
going to be just in the same i wasn't
sure like i saw the trailer for it and i
was just kind of like well is this like
an offshoot or because i thought they
were doing shazam 2 like literally so
maybe black adam is like a offshoot but
like in the same universe like they're
trying to do like a crossover i'm not
really sure that's got dwayne johnson
that's good dwayne johnson's good play
play black adam that's gonna be that's
gonna be good and he i think he produced
uh shazam the first one or very partly
produced it i don't really know but i
remember that
like day opening day
or day two
uh because you know i got i got the rock
on instagram
and uh he posted he goes oh man i'm glad
you guys like the movie the [ __ ] is the
numbers are looking great we're gonna go
ahead and do the second one it's all
ready we're gonna do another i'll do
another one
so he was already putting the money up
for another one and i don't i guess
that's black adam
yeah you know and i guess shazam is to
be in it and some people might laugh at
me i [ __ ] love i like shazam
better than [ __ ] the mcu i didn't
really i don't like the marvel ones too
much i think they're full of themselves
and
more like a ride at disneyland where
it's just all style no real substance
there's just too many goddamn characters
i don't really care about them there's
they're not really fun to watch
um
no i like the [ __ ] marvel daredevil
[ __ ] on uh series the series are
pretty good especially daredevil one and
two
jessica jones was real good luke cage
was real good
unfortunately
the punisher was disappointing because
they tried to they just they watered
that character i wasn't crazy about iron
fist either yeah kind of that was a
little bland right
and uh i had high hopes for [ __ ]
punisher got through the first season
and i was like and i got partly way
through the second season second season
was a little bit better
but the punisher has to be [ __ ]
intimidating and he has to be basically
a bad guy
before me he was great in [ __ ] uh
daredevil that's the punisher
you know
sheila and says william defoe pops up in
the hunger yeah he was he was in like uh
he was in there for literally two
seconds like as some kind of junkie like
leaning against a phone booth i don't
know if that was like his first role
but i thought that was kind of funny um
yeah somebody's saying like guillermo
del toro a lot of his stuff is not set
in the present day yeah that's true now
that now that you mention it all of his
yeah because a lot of his stuff well
pan's labyrinth and
uh devil's backbone that was set during
the spanish civil war
i haven't seen the shape of water yet
i keep meaning to watch it but it's just
like i haven't seen it i know it got
didn't it we won like best picture i
think when it came out i still haven't
got around to seeing it says black
adam's part of the shazam group of
characters so it's kind of a sequel okay
yeah okay so it's gonna run alongside it
that's what i thought i thought it was
going to be two separate movies like
that was the impression i got i don't
have shazam on blu-ray i need to get
that [ __ ] on blu-ray oh yeah yeah i was
gonna get it i never got around to
buying it
yeah i liked it i liked that and another
one that i liked was uh into the spider
verse the animated one i thought that
was great that was great that was
fantastic actually yeah
but you know well it's i thought they
were making a sequel to that too yeah
and i thought that one was going to be a
loser but it the spider-verse but not i
[ __ ] loved it yeah i wanted i want a
whole animated film of the noir
spider-man the black and white one from
the yeah in the 40s that have been
[ __ ] great
30s and 40s i mean i'm pretty sure
they're doing more with that yeah um i
don't know if each one is getting their
own offshoot movie or something like
that but i thought that they were
working on something along those lines
some superhero stuff only works in
[ __ ] animation
some of it can only be anime it doesn't
make sense in live action some of it um
i was [ __ ] real pleased with [ __ ]
both venoms
i liked them both and i don't have
either one on blue raggedy yeah those
were fun i liked them both
some stuff
feels true to the superhero
genre some of it doesn't and it's part
of that mcu stuff just didn't feel true
to the to comic books to me
um but you know everybody has their own
opinions you know most people love the
the the
yeah and i'm not saying they're wrong
i'm just saying that
i liked them i just they weren't real i
didn't really get all that emotionally
invested they're kind of generic
yeah that's yeah that's from my point of
view they just did seem kind of very
little um
and you know [ __ ]
the new superman not that good man
[ __ ] superman one two
one and two from and the donner cut of
[ __ ] superman two [ __ ] yeah you
know hard to beat chris reeves
um
they're just i don't know
what else was good for from [ __ ]
superheroes
uh i don't really know i'm not yeah
the old spidermans were pretty good with
with toby maguire they're pretty good
yeah
um i mean like i said you know we'll
maybe see the new one but
um
you know it's not gonna be because
honestly there was some other movies
that i wanted to see before
that i mean i wouldn't actually mind
seeing house of gucci yeah i gotta see
that one look good that actually looked
pretty good yeah that looked like a lot
of campy fun
and um you know i'm like oh i'm into it
but uh yeah i mean i i was expecting to
like this one
but
i liked it way more than i was expecting
because i kind of went into it because
like i said i hadn't seen the book i
hadn't read the book i hadn't seen the
original uh i knew it was some kind of
like nourish carny thing but i didn't
really know like what the story was
gonna be so i was just kind of like i'm
just gonna go see it like kind of sight
unseen and man it was like really real
all the [ __ ] acting is good in it it
was just oracle said they are making a
sequel to spider-verse yeah i thought
they were i thought they were
uh pat says i enjoyed the dolph lundgren
version of the punisher believe it or
not his acting was not good
and i don't know how it compared to the
comics but i liked it as a sort of
drive-in action movie i think i've seen
that but it's been so long that i can't
like remember
evidently mango didn't like the house of
gucci i can tell by just where he's
talking yeah i've seen house of gucci
let me know what you think of it if you
see it
well i mean we you know we we already
have the amc stub so and pat has agrees
with me man [ __ ] um
uh chris chris reeves was the [ __ ] he
was
he that was superman
now superman three and four you know
they kind of
not good not you know superman four was
a [ __ ] disaster i got it i still
haven't seen it yet somebody sent it to
him sent me all of them
i haven't got as far as four but i heard
that four is so [ __ ] out there that
it that it might it's a canon film it's
so bad it might be good
i guess we'll have to get drunk one
night
[Laughter]
i remember seeing superman four just on
hbo when it came out and i looked at it
like a couple seconds ah no you could
already tell yeah you turned it nope
notice i never even got through it
superman 4 is one of those movies where
even even if you look at stills from the
movie you can tell that it's not good
it's like turkish superman it was like
on a lot turkey it was like a turkish
superman movie oh my god it's what it
looked like all those turkish rip-offs
but some people says no man you got to
see it it's [ __ ] hilarious
i'll check it out when i get around to
it yeah we do have it we just have it
yeah we just we just haven't pulled the
trigger
oh my god all right so uh you want to
wrap it up yeah i'm kind of i'm kind of
sleepy to be honest with you even though
i just i got sleep i don't know yeah
but yeah
uh if yeah if you want to see like an
actual
r-rated
uh you know adult-oriented drama
about carnies and [ __ ] like that like in
noir because this is like really [ __ ]
good like i said some people are
complaining it's like oh it's a little
too long [ __ ] that yeah people got atd i
don't know i guess
i did i did not yeah it's long but it's
that did not bother me in the slightest
let me throw some add in there i want to
say something before we shut it down
another one i'm pissed off is that
whatever happened to our [ __ ] sequel
of [ __ ] battle angel
elite of battle angel was [ __ ] great
yeah but how long is that gonna take him
to make not a peep and evidently they
kept kept a bunch of expensive
live-action sets and [ __ ] to continue to
make that
and uh i thought that was great man it
was much better than ghost in the shell
and ghost in the shell wasn't as bad as
people said it was it's just that i
think they their hopes were real high
based on the manga the the fans didn't
like it but battle angel i thought that
was great man they would set up a good
[ __ ]
a good [ __ ] character
i wanted to find out more about the
martian wars and
and the [ __ ] battle angels and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] how they did [ __ ] and i
thought it was cool cyber cyborgs
i guess mango's talking about house of
gucci but it says it has some good
performances but it's a bit of a mess in
my view lots of actors chewing the
scenery oh now i really want to watch it
[Laughter]
like i said i kind of feel like i'm
going to go into it with it just being
like over the top and like campy and i'm
just like i'll try to enjoy it on that
level well in a way in a way there's
been some good movies like that adam
sandler movie you [ __ ] what he played
the damn gangster was it was all over
the place it was uncut
is a [ __ ] masterpiece it was it's
great and i'm not a huge sandler fan i'm
not either but if you want to see a cool
[ __ ] gangster movie about jewish
gangsters down in the [ __ ] diamond
district see that one
that was [ __ ] bad i told you that
that movie like made me like have
anxiety yeah that was one of the most
anxiety-inducing movies i've ever
watched talk about
talk about grifton
that dude was grifting and scamming 24
7. how the [ __ ] did he do this with
other people's money yeah
and because this is what i do
it's just oh man
oscar says jenny what's your exact cash
app name i think it's just jenny ashford
j-n-n-n-n-y-m-s-h f-o-r-d
you get
with a space in between i think so it's
i think it's just my actual name i'd
have to look though
is she is she laying on her back she's
trying to get it like a weirdo yeah
that's yeah that's what she does she's
like who said that being drunk is the
best way to watch superman that's kind
of
one of these days yeah
maybe we should watch it tonight do a
matinee on it we we got to do uh
identity as well because rob says that
oracle said chris reeves was one of
those actors who embraced uh who
embraced not just the superhero role but
the legacy knowing that so many kids
would see him as superman i agree i mean
he just seemed like a good dude overall
yeah you know superman the superman
character and this is what's missing out
of the new superman's
superman himself has
an intense level of
of purity to him he has to be very
morally pure you have to [ __ ] suspect
this due to being a virgin
and that's [ __ ] superman
that is superman yeah
he is
superman
when you when you look at the superman
you have the
you're gonna be that's the kind of dude
that actually doesn't get in the ass
like
he's afraid of hurting that woman's
feelings he's got to protect her feels
because he can't because he got to be
superman he can't have children in her
family he's got to go he got to save the
world and [ __ ] so he's he's got to be
kind of an angelic being
they they are based upon angels l means
[ __ ] god
you know uh
khalel and journal
and [ __ ] yeah and this is all
this is all a retelling of [ __ ]
in a way jesus
god and the son of god
it is it is a jewish story
um
it's basically about
a jewish kid
sent
to america to escape [ __ ] fascism you
know the nazis
so that's what my cash app is so it's
the little dollar sign of jenny oh it's
all run together yeah or try jennifer
ashby right see i can't even remember i
don't use i don't use this that often
so i don't really know but that's what
it is so superman's got to be kind of
boyish
he can't be dark there's no way of you
can't have a dark superman really yeah
some superheroes you can do like gritty
reboots but yeah superman i mean you can
do it i'm not saying you can't superman
had dark moments even in the chris
reeves versions when he went bad for the
[ __ ] the poisoning from the goddamn
[ __ ] what they call it the the
the man-made kryptonite you know what i
mean and he
so there are times when he had dark
moments but
but superman has to be
a character of moral purity
or you don't buy into it
yeah you know
uh yeah mango says superman four is bad
with a capital b but a must see back
crazy fun okay
let's watch so tonight let's watch
identity and superman four and then
we'll do matinees on those well because
we need like two movies because
tomorrow night we can't watch a movie
because we're going to memento mori the
christmas memento mori
at the
club yeah so we won't be able to watch
so we got to watch two movies tonight
yeah
oscar's telling me how to slander
christmas
oscar he sent you something oh okay let
me look see what's going on i keep my
phone over there
wait where'd it go what's happening
what's happening
i don't know
what's happening
michael says that's a good dub of double
bill
yeah
well those are the two that we have like
to you know watch so
okay
all right did you get it thank you very
much how much was the super chat well
hold on hold on hold on hold on i'm not
really sure because like i said i don't
really like use this all that often she
doesn't really know how to use it yeah
like i said i only got it because i had
one friend that was like using it and i
don't really know and i don't even have
a bio it's look i have a wrong of my
wrong address is on there still i'll
think i'll figure it out
i'll figure it out later
i don't know what's happening uh but
yeah so she doesn't know how to thank
you so thank you very much yeah how much
was it bro
five probably five yeah like don't worry
about it
[Laughter]
all right so are we done so yeah go go
see nightmare alley everybody okay i
mean yeah oh yeah well worth it that's
when you should see it in the in the
theater i mean i really liked it i
thought it was really really good um but
yeah it's two and a half so it's true
yeah so if you think it's gonna be
longer if you think it's gonna be slow
then then don't like don't go see it but
i mean i recommend it i thought it was
amazing i thought it was like really
really good just it's a certain kind of
movie it'll it'll kind of pull you in
yeah i totally got sucked in like i said
it didn't seem long to me at all because
i was just like
i was totally like fascinated by it all
right so tomorrow we'll be back talking
about either identity or superman 4.
we're not going to tell you which one we
don't know which one we don't know yet
we'll figure it out but yeah so uh have
a good rest of your weekend everybody
thanks for super chats and donations and
all that kind of stuff and uh we'll see
you guys again tomorrow afternoon